okay some really interesting posts
popped up this morning on the david
pakman show
reddit i encourage you to uh participate
at davidpakman.com reddit we are
just 90 or so subscribers short on the
reddit of twenty thousand
uh it's free subscribe at
davidpakman.com slash reddit user record
58 or rickard posted 100 reasons
not to vote for donald trump in november
and
in reading this the the point and
they're all
perfectly good reasons including trump's
continued lies i mean just to pick one
thing
he said he would release his tax returns
he still hadn't right i mean just like
you could pick any one of these things
uh the the tariff
with china disaster failed coronavirus
responds on and on and on
uh there are people who are arguing
that democrats want things to be worse
for the next five months
economically and in terms of the virus
to justify removing donald trump and to
every single one of them i continue to
say
trump could stop doing bad things
today and not do another quote bad thing
for the next five months
he would still deserve to be removed in
other words as
a person who cares about others i want
the economy to recover as quickly as
possible and i don't want a single
additional person to die of coronavirus
and even if that happened
today i would still vote to remove
donald trump because of what he's
already done and i think that's an
important thing to keep in mind when
these right-wingers talk about
you're trying to make coronavirus worse
to hurt trump
like no the the case for removing trump
has been written already
and um again as i said if he
solves every uh geopolitical conflict
and cures all disease in the next five
months
come back to me and we can talk about it
but just look at what he's done for the
last three and a half years that has
that that is a ticket to uh removal from
the white house if i've ever seen one
also from the david pakman show
subreddit karaoke
24 asks if mitt romney was to support
and endorse joe biden
do you think there's a chance biden
could win utah or is utah too deep red
i tweeted something similar the other
day here's my thought
i think that if mitt romney were to
endorse biden
it would force trump to have to fight
for utah
i don't think trump will ultimately lose
utah utah
is very very conservative one of the
most conservative states in the country
however even in polling now it's closer
than it usually is
and certainly if romney were to endorse
biden trump would have to spend money in
utah and that would be a victory because
every dollar
trump has to spend to hold utah is a
dollar he can't spend
in wisconsin or ohio or pennsylvania or
other states that are more likely
to make a difference so i hope romney
does endorse joe biden i already talked
earlier this week about
how some on the left are kind of missing
the mark in terms of interpreting
some of these republicans who are saying
i can't i can't go
i can't vote for trump i just can't do
it uh so i would love to see it i don't
think it gives utah to joe biden
but i think it does give trump a problem
where he has to spend money in utah
a lot of posts i'm picking just one here
but a lot of posts
thrilled about my 35 minute interview
slash
therapy session on tuesday evening
with streamer stephen kenneth
destiny bonnell ii now i know some of
you guys may not know who he is
he's a figure in the twitch gaming
community it also
does a lot of political debates and
here's just one of the
posts about this david and destiny
should make a podcast
that was some of the best funny content
i've seen in a while we should honestly
have a david and destiny podcast they're
both pretty funny
and know a lot about the issues i think
there is a lot of demand for a podcast
on both
fan bases many requests for this
uh you know for now it probably is going
to have to remain
a sort of check in every once in a while
because i'm pretty busy with everything
i've got going on but i really do
appreciate that people seem to uh to
like that if you missed it on the live
stream we put the full 35 minute
interview with stephen kenneth on the
youtube channel and you can find it at
youtube.com slash the david pakman show
and find all of these discussions that
you can participate in
at davidpakman.com reddit
or search for the david pakman show in
the reddit app